A new study says if you wanna lose weight,
low-carb is the way to go!
You heard it here: you can eat all the fat
you want now!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and over the
past couple of decades, the low-carb diet
has been front and center in almost every
single diet plan out there.
The problem is, there haven’t been any long-term
studies, showing that it’s more effective
for weight loss than a low-fat diet.
UNTIL NOW.
A new study published this week in the Annals
of Internal Medicine, followed 150 obese men
and women for an entire year - who were randomly
assigned to either a low-carb or a low-fat
diet.
About half of the participants were white,
the other half were black - and none of them
had any history of heart problems or diabetes
when the study began.
People in the low-carb group were asked to
eat fewer than 40 grams of carbohydrates a
day, while those in the low-fat group were
asked to keep their daily calorie intake at
less than 30% calories from fat and 55% calories
from carbs.
Neither group was explicitly asked to restrict
their total number of calories, but they did
attend a series of nutritional and support
sessions over the course of the study.
And after the year was over, the results pretty
much spoke for themselves.
The participants were who on low-carb diets,
lost an average total of 12 pounds, versus
only about 4 pounds for people on low-fat
diets.
That’s a pretty significant difference - but
what’s even better, is that their heart
health actually improved on a low-carb diet.
They had less inflammation, as well as better
cholesterol and improved triglyceride levels
- two key hallmarks of good cardiovascular
health.
Also interesting, is the fact that people
on low-carb diets, lost weight - but also
increased their lean muscle mass.
On the flip side, people in the low-fat group,
actually lost more muscle, compared to fat.
Of course, this study only examined the effects
of those diets for a year, so it’s unclear
how they’d fare over 3, 5, or even 10 years
- but for the short term at least, it seems
low-carb is absolutely the way to go.
Even if you don’t need to lose weight, the
benefits it has for your heart - are pretty
undeniable.
And while we’re on the topic of things that
are good for you, let me remind everyone that
I host another show here on Discovery, called
Anyhoo.
And a couple weeks ago, we did an episode
on salt - and all of the myths surrounding
it.
So if you wanna know more about that, feel
free to check us out at youtube.com/revision3.
In the meantime, let us know in the comments
below if you’ve gone on a diet - and which
one was most successful for you.
That’s all for me, but as always - thank
you guys for watching.